prima di cominciare con il gameplay
ragazzi volevo dirvi che la data del
made in internet dell'altro giorno
quindi domenica scorsa a firenze è
andata sold out quindi ringrazio tutti
quanti in questa domenica saremo a
milano come sono super gasato volevo
dirlo anche nel video e quindi ragazzi
prima di partire sigla sa che il
giurista ma no a no
amazon
[Musica]
anat superate tira verso le dimissioni
si può essere allora ascoltate da tutti
ragazzi di questo nome io devo farvi
capire una roba quando l'ultima volta
giocata sta roba
mi è venuto un po dopo tanto troppo
troppo anzi da vomitare siamo tornati su
sagge riscuote barca vacca che culo è
c'è questo sito che va chi non lo
conoscesse i team schifo ti spiega anzi
ti fa fare le cose chirurgiche belle per
quelle sopra prima di mangiare se giochi
a questo gioco ti aumenta l'appetito
l'ultima volta abbiamo fatto delle cose
che non mi ricordo perché mi ci sono
volute due o tre sedute dallo psichiatra
per dimenticarle direi che oggi possiamo
buttarci sul far nascere i bambini
siete citatissimi proviamoci nasce
natural childbirth quanto lento ma
regalo è bene non mi dovete far vedere
tutto è gente che sta caricando la mappa
di gta 5 ragazzi a non capisco niente di
quello che dice no interesse 6 giugno
ebbene io ti sto capendo c'è una nuda
fammi capire io io mi auto insegno
signori anzi donne non sono capaci io ci
provo e rocco tutta se stesso però non
sono capace a fa nasceva minya ma appena
sfornato io click bearing di kate c'è
chi ne position the baby clicca dove è
indicato per guardare la posizione del
bambino vero e ring l'esoso poi
conversare con la paziente in inglese
finché il bambino nascerà solo questo
giannini vai clico ace un bambino li
dentro anche signora c'è un bambino qua
non lo sapeva vero e devo dico io che
sono dottore studiato io sto bene qua
qua scommetto che c'è la testa
mica quanti anni di studio per capire
queste cose rotte le acque rotte le
acque
prendi le bottiglie che un casino qua
nei periodi di secca 40 minuti o cuscini
slater anche sydney di saccani mio dio
ma che cazzo sto vedendo stai zitta che
già fa schifo per l'amore di gesù
signori
meno male che ho fatto l'ho youtuber
cliccare qua sulla fuga fagiana nome sto
vedendo le europee fanno veramente
schifo meno male che censurato regata
non so ancora come censurerò questo
video ma grazie a dio è censurato perché
sarah è uscita la testa non vedete mai
uscita ve lo giuro
dovreste fare con fava at the baby from
the birth canal ok devo tirare fuori i
bambini arca vaccoli raga fosse posso
farle uscire rimetterlo dentro a mio
piacimento
non so quanto sia contenta di questa
cosa in questo momento però lo sto
facendo
ok è uscito forse ti sei fatta male però
grazie sono bravissimo stai zitto che
dai fastidio ecco che lo fa qua ha
subito lario soul immediatamente ecco
basso io che sono sempre i fazzoletti
che ci hanno sempre chiuso
devo tagliare il cordone ombelicale
vai stacca stacca stacca stacca che un
casino non sono capace a staccare il
colore americane aiuto a sono delle
forcine bene grazie
bene a me la bambina è una dolce
ragazzina è una bimba chiamiamola come
il dottore che l'ha partorita lorenza
non mi interessa quanti pannolini vado a
sprecare vada bene così
vabbè ai ragazzi abbiamo finito il parco
ed è stato un parto non era bella
battuta ci sono tante altre cose che
vedo che sono fantastiche tra tutte
quante se proprio devo scegliere
facciamo l'estrazione del dente che mi
sembra una delle più tranquille visto
che adesso abbiamo un attimo cioè essere
easy visto che già non dormo più st nota
almeno facciamo una cosa un po più easy
nel caricamento dei denti come potete
vedere ci mette di meno perché per
troyer e un dente non ci vogliono nove
mesi ma 5 minuti
sbatti la testa forte contro la porta
scene metti anche meno cosa non si fa
per farle
ciao zio vita è rimasto di quell'altra
volta george f estrazione devo usare un
dental elevator lusenti per ion di
entare legamente nelle vede tutto using
a detta delle non ho capito niente di
come c'è scritto sono capitate che è un
articolo cosa abbiamo capito da tutto
questo
niente solo che la dottore l'ultima
volta non ha funzionato trapianto di
capelli perché ancora mezzo pelato
questo l'abbiamo capito allora devo
essere questo click deve interforze
toulouse e nelle multe tour asp per
togliere il dente cioè devi far leva
tiple piede di porco rega vabbè ma devo
rischiare il sangue bene voglio fare il
dentista voglio fare il dentista da
domani trattare l'acqua che cosa può mai
fare l'acqua quando c'è un buco così
gigante in bocca sac the water sacche
the water e lui cosa ci mettiamo fine a
devo ammettere la garza
sì ma il paziente che non al dente cosa
fa a quello era il dente del giudizio
grazie ragazzi ce l'abbiamo fatta anche
noi non ce lo rifaccio trapianti in
testa te l'ho già fatto una volta mi ha
fatto vomitare non è servito a niente te
lo tieni adesso
tieniti i capelli che hai loncar a gare
le pene a me perché non tariffari
va bè ragazzi io direi di scegliere
l'ultima cosa da fare oggi che è
veramente un po più integrale delle
altre
l'ultima volta l'ho toccata e oggi la
facciamo perché assolutamente va fatta
non so se ve lo ricordate ma tra tutte
le operazioni che si possono fare ce n'è
una in particolare che mi attira un
sacco che come cucinare il tacchino
perché in mezzo alle aree cosa va bene
come cucinare un tacchino vai fa vj
facci vedere altro che già lo zafferano
qua da domani canale di cucina
nuotano gioisco ma tu fai qualcosa
tornare a vita cose normali che sei
parte prego però vedo che ha trovato
un'alternativa ai capelli turchi
preparation spiega mantica dove indicato
per chi si reca mi fa piu schifo questo
che fa l'operazione di givi giuro vabbè
grazie devo mettere il burro sul
tacchino perfetto perché fa bene al
colesterolo lubrifica bene le vene passa
bene tutto nelle vene bene poi c'è del
tacchino in questo burro continua click
drag the season detto erkic si vai a spa
scalo di pepe e sale arca vaccara league
cannavacciuolo che può accompagnare solo
vai così vanti del back invernale swan
45 minuti la facciamo più c'è chi chiede
ok perché ma dobbiamo ancora mettere
immagino a noi l'abbiamo l'abbiamo tolto
che c'è praticamente c'è un termometro
che si infila dentro il tacchino che ti
dice quante quant'è la temperatura socio
maria eva subito fu ultimamente hanno
ancora dentro
forty five minutes later tagliare le
gambe taglia le zampe ruta kin one stuta
china niente devo togliere la gamba al
tacchino regasto video vi sta facendo
diventare vegan ove lo giuro che cos'è
mai sicuro sta usando a sprazzi da
giandomenico questa roba non so il
termometro è l'ala cosina
e dico veramente la facciamo bene dopo
tagliatutto tacchino me lo fai tagli a
tutto meno fatta via tutto bene perfetto
contiamo così tutto il giorno rega si
chiuderà scegliamo dopo cena va bene con
una vittima torpedo agiata presto
far.pro per di gesti che ha detto anche
cosa devi fare dopo che l'hai mangiato
come un paziente devi devi riposare per
digerirlo va beh gli utili già tre razze
jazz grazie grazie grazie fratello la
prossima volta però premiarti invece di
farti trapianto in testa di capelli ti
faccio trapianto di tacchino ragazzi
miei io basta però oggi guardava bene ho
fatto per oggi va bene così chiudo qua
sono contento e soddisfatto del mio
lavoro da youtube era ogni giorno di più
quindi ragazzi mesi spero che a video vi
sia piaciuto come adesso mi devi
piaciuto cemento mi piace adesso sapete
come far nascere i bambini e i tacchini
dalle facce se farete nascere ma in
bambino magari riesce il tacchino con un
casino mi sia piaciuto ragazzi con se si
riuscisse ovviamente mi piace anche per
le società che mi ha dato notizia le
sono sempre se siete ci vediamo l'anno
prossimo visto da ragazzi